how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe ever since
avengers in game was released and tony
stark made the ultimate sacrifice
delivering the ultimate one-liner we've
ever heard so far in the marvel
cinematic
iron universe fans have been wondering
if
iron man tony stark is really done is
robert downey jr done
playing the role there's been a lot of
rumors and speculation recently that
robert downey jr could return to the mcu
so far the projects that he's done after
avengers in-game such as
doolittle haven't exactly performed that
well and many fans are wondering if this
is something that could bring robert
downey jr back to his role of
iron man well robert downey jr was
recently on a podcast where he was asked
about this and he has finally addressed
whether or not he is done with iron man
so i'll break down
everything that you need to know about
what he said and what it means for the
future of the mcu
in this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
all the latest
mcu news and so you can enter this
week's giveaway for a chance to win
a hawkeye funko pop all you got to do to
enter subscribe
like the video and leave a comment down
below so the podcast that robert downey
jr was on is called the smartless
podcast the smartless podcast is hosted
by three famous and hilarious actors
jason bateman sean hayes and will arnett
and while they had robert downey jr on
their podcast they asked him how family
life was going after avengers in game
and talk to him about his obligations to
the mcu as iron man
right now in which he replied with a
simple that's all done
so as of right now robert downey jr has
no contractual
obligations to marvel studios meaning
that he is not going to be appearing in
any mcu film anytime soon that is
unless it's something that has already
been filmed such as black widow
there has been a really big black widow
leak that says robert downing jr is
going to be appearing in the black widow
film
making a cameo in some way shape or form
the leak says that after the events of
civil war
tony will go and try to bring natasha
back in kindly when she refuses to go
back in tony stark actually helps her
this of course is not confirmed but is a
big leak that is said to happen
but the most important part about what
he said that's all done
it means he's referring to his
commitments to filming marvel movies
right now
that doesn't necessarily mean that he
won't ever come back
maybe years down the line in fact most
people do think that he is going to come
back for avengers
secret wars especially since doctor
strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to introduce the
multiverse to our marvel cinematic
universe
basically alternate realities and
different universes intercrossing with
one another is about to happen in the
mcu and what this does is open up a way
for robert downey jr to return
as tony stark as iron man without
actually offsetting his death and
sacrifice from avengers in game because
that's the problem with bringing
robert downey jr back as iron man his
sacrifice was the greatest sacrifice of
the mcu and if you bring him back
you take away that sacrifice you take
away its meaning but
not if you'd bring him back to play an
alternate version of tony stark a tony
stark from a different
universe in avengers secret wars battle
world
the multiverse kind of explodes and all
of the different universes collide into
one
so doing this you see multiple versions
of the same character meet each other
you see many different captain americas
from different universes you see many
different thors and you see many
different iron mans
so this would be the opportunity for
robert downey jr to return if he ever so
wanted to
and this also means that chris evans
could return to make a cameo as well as
an alternate version of himself from a
different universe
and yes even black widow herself could
show up
hey if michael keaton can return as the
batman 30-something years later then
robert downey jr can return as iron man
10 years down the road
but right now with the exception of
black widow don't expect him to appear
in any mcu movies anytime soon
because like he said as for now that's
all done it's sad but
it is time he sacrificed himself in
avengers in-game and now he's moving on
he will always be missed but we have a
lot more to look forward to with the
next few phases of the mcu
and of course his possible return 10
years or so down the road
in avengers secret wars battle world so
let me know what you think about robert
downey jr being done with the mcu right
now do you think it's a good idea that
iron man is not returning anytime soon
or would you like to see him
leave all your thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you stay up to
date on all the latest
mcu news for live updates you can follow
me on twitter and instagram and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof